first off what we know that there were
job cuts before in the prior transaction
what is the talk now about job cuts here
after the two merge well yeah that's a
that's a great question Betty what we
know is that job cuts are one part of
the 3g playbook I mean they are
incredibly ruthless about getting costs
out of a business improving operating
margins you said in the intro you talked
about the 7,000 job cuts at Heinz and
frankly we don't know what the exact
cuts are going to look like at Kraft but
I think it's safe according to the
analysts and investors I spoke with to
assume that that those are coming and
how much does Buffett have an influence
over that strategy between himself and
3G you know how much you know how much
do they consult with him when they're
looking at restructuring and rebranding
these companies well one thing I know I
don't think they're going to be looking
to rebrand these companies they really
do like the brands if you listen to what
Warren Buffett said or the guys at 3G
have said they like these brands Buffett
is really gonna let 3G run this
operation he said that all along that
he's more of a financing partner so I
think the way to look at this is just is
is is more as Buffett trust these guys
as managers he knows what their playbook
is and he's just gonna let them execute
now how much money does this leave for
Buffett Noah a pretty staggering amount
I mean he had more than 60 billion at
the end of last year the way this deal
is structured he's going to be adding
he's going to be paying maybe a little
bit more than five billion more to pay
this special dividend that Kraft
shareholders are going to get but that
leaves just a lot a lot of money for him
to do another deal that the real
question is you know when is that going
to come along if when is something gonna
come along that tempts him right and you
know Noah's you and I know with more
Buffett it could come along as soon as
tomorrow right it's always a possibility
and he has this close relationship you
know we've seen George lemon at the
Berkshire Hathaway annual meeting over
the last several years the two of them
seem to get along really well what do
you think it is Noah well look the the
partnership makes sense right now for
Berkshire and its evolution
Buffett has as we just talked about all
of this cash and he needs help finding
places to put it to work and more than
that there are a lot of companies out
there where he might like the brands he
might like a lot that's going for the
company but maybe he would feel more
confident if there's a different
management team in place
so what 3G delivers is a management team
and ideas now on the other hand 3G
obviously gets the capital from
Berkshire and you know it's often talked
about the Buffett has this halo so when
he goes in and does a deal right you
know there's a reputation that he brings
to to the table I know it just quickly I
mean it you know you can't help but
notice that Buffett seems to have a real
inkling for food companies real passion
for them you know is there anything to
be drawn from the fact that a lot of his
acquisitions have to do with food and
consumer consumer goods nothing other
than I think he understands them I mean
this is what he's done for for 50-plus
years is he investing companies that he
can wrap his mind around and I would I
would say that that fits in this these
fit in that category